gentil et le visage de relais en direct
entre leur darcos merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité est philippe juvin que
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir bonjour je
vous remercie beaucoup d'attentes
invités politiques ce matin hsbc un des
urgences à l'hôpital pompidou à paris
maire de la garenne colombes
c'est dans les hauts-de-seine candidat
aux législatives dans les hauts-de-seine
sous l'étiquette des républicains est
justement on va parler de ce qui se
passe dans votre partie puisque ce matin
dans le figaro damien abad annonce donc
qu'il quitte la présidence du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale qui se met en
retrait des républicains qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous je pense qu'il a bien
fait de clarifier les choses il a fait
un choix politique
il l'assumé voilà la vie politique est
faite de choix donc aux droites sur ce
qu'il dit d'abord est ce que christian
jacob a eu raison lui ai demandé de
partir pour la wii je pense d'ailleurs
je crois que abad je leur ai fait
spontanément vous choisissez comme ça
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'il est un
petit peu attendu la composition à venir
du gouvernement pour faire son choix on
verra ils sont tannés de grâce c'est le
cas il se trouve que j'ai eu moi une au
sein de l'ue comité stratégique des
républiques à une position assez
similaire à lui c'est que la même vous
n'avez pas besoin que je crois je crois
si vous voulez que dans une situation
d'extrême crise les partis de
gouvernement doivent trouver des accords
de gouvernement entre eux maintenant
j'ai fait un choix différent moi je suis
resté aux républicains d'ailleurs je
suis jamais je n'ai jamais quitté
républicain peut-être pour une raison
principale
peut-être deux la première raison c'est
que en démocratie alors même que les
partis d'opposition et de gouvernement
une majorité peuvent travailler ensemble
ce que je demande ça ses premiers points
il ya un poids très fondamental ça va
être le message de ce matin c'est que
lors de cette élection législative ce
qui va compter c'est pas de savoir qui
va gagner on sait que la majorité
présidentielle le parti des manuels
mâcon va gagner c'est fait ils vont
gagner la question c'est qui arrive
numéro 2 pourquoi parce que ce qui
arrive numéro 2 c'est à dire le plus
grand parti d'opposition a des pouvoirs
extrêmement important à l'assemblée
nationale en particulier ce qu'on
appelle la présidence de la commission
des finances est ce que vous imaginez
la présidence de la commission des
finances à la france a soumises jeu je
préfère ne pas l'imaginer donc moi je
dis simplement aux français qui nous
écoutent vous avez donné et vous allez
donner une majorité la très large
d'ailleurs à emmanuel macron ils vont
vous et là il aura la majorité absolue
les manuels nos médias bien pas de c'est
pas ça se fait toujours le l'histoire
mais depuis cinquante-huit vème
république le président il a toujours
gagné des initiatives en tout cas quand
ce l'élection a eu lieu après l'élection
présidentielle toujours donc ce n'est
pas un sujet c'est vrai que vous aimez
bien pardon et les journalistes et tout
le monde créé une sorte de feuilleton
est ce que ça va marcher ou pas et jean
luc mélenchon c'est jean-luc mélanger
avant évidemment donc pour vous aimons
marine le pen dit c'est demain jeudi
c'est quelqu'un de la crau il à sa
majorité précieux les châtie ville va
l'avoir donc il va pouvoir gérer la
vraie question que les français doivent
comprendre c'est maintenant s'ils votent
pour la france a soumis il se met dans
une situation où c'est la france a
soumises qui va être numéro 2 c'est à
dire avoir la présidence de la
commission des finances moi je dis aux
français je pense que pour le pouvoir
d'achat pour la bonne santé de
l'économie pour mille choses d'
équilibre il vaut mieux que ce soient
les républicains nous sommes des gens
responsables qui est la présidence de la
commission des finances donc voilà votez
pour les républicains
pour faire en sorte qu'il ya un
équilibre raisonnable de pouvoir
raisonnable pour revenir à damien m
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
retenir de cette interview il vous cite
notamment dans cette interview dans le
figaro il dit je croyais pouvoir faire
bouger les lignes de l'intérieur je ne
suis pas tout seul d'autres pensent
comme moi tels jean françois copé ou
philippe juvin vous pensez comme moi là
dessus non je jeu mais encore une fois
au comité stratégique j'ai eu la même
position que lui qui est la suivante la
france est fracturée
70% des français se sont soit abstenue
soit ont voté pour un parti qui veut
casser casser la baraque c'est très
extrêmement grave il ya un grand
fractionnement du corps social et donc
dans ces situations là moi j'ai été
député européen pendant dix ans et j'ai
vu l'exercice démocratique qui se passe
chez nous voisins exercice démocratique
chez nos voisins c'est de dire qu'il ya
un moment dans ces situations de crise
est bien où les partis de droite de
gauche du centre raisonnable raisonnable
et aux républicains nous sommes les gens
raisonnables travaillent ensemble c'est
ça que j'ai dit
malheureusement je suis minoritaire de
mon parti un public a donc je vais pas y
revenir c'est comme ça je suis candidat
républicain g contre moi une une
candidate une candidate de la république
en marche voilà j'assume c'est comment
vous l'expliquez comment vous expliquez
que damien abad lui n'a pas de candidat
de la majorité présidentielle face à lui
et vous vous en avez 1 alors que vous
avez une position similaire à savoir pas
d'indépendance on souhaite travailler
avec le gouvernement mais parce que moi
je souhaitais dire une chose suivante
c'est que cette collaboration de
gouvernement elle se fait alors même que
je reste aux républicains sochaux mais
je ne passe pas dans la majorité
présidentielle je voulais vous avez été
tenté de le faire un nom mais moi on m'a
proposé j'ai je veux on a proposé un
appel on vous dit est ce que
éventuellement vous rejoins driller sous
l'étiquette sous la bannière de la
majorité présidentielle le président de
la république non moi je suis prêt idée
de président de la république et toute
personne raisonnable gérer pays mais
avec ma bannière du républicain se
chevauchent ce qui n'a jamais été tenté
de quitter votre partenaire mais je suis
je veux sans jamais citer les
républicains grimper encore bien quand
ça allait mal il ya quelques années vous
sentez encore à l'aise dans ce parti
vous êtes minoritaires vous le dire je
suis très minoritaire c'est sûr mais je
crois comme je vous le dis qu'il faut
des partis d'opposition raisonnable dans
une démocratie à dire que c'est
compliqué d'imaginer que dans un grand
parti de pays comme la france on va
avoir uniquement une opposition
déraisonnable la france assume isa
soumises ou madame le pen quel que soit
d'ailleurs
la bonne volonté de tous ces gens que je
met pas du tout en cause mais je pense
que l'or je pense que tout simplement
leurs propositions ne sont pas
raisonnables est-ce que damien abad il
fait ce jeu là en rejoignant la majorité
présidentielle même si pour le moment il
a rejoint pas mais en tout cas on ne
vote pas recycler le jeu du fait d'avoir
une opposition qui se résumerait à
marine le pen où j'ai passé le risque
est donc assez bien
oui c'est le risque bien entendu moi si
vous voulez est-ce qu'il affaiblit la
république avec cette décision quand
toute personne qui quitte à parti
affaibli le parti qu'ils quittent jeu si
vous voulez je pense que
je pense que la question est toujours
une question de casting de personnes et
c'est ça qui brouillent le message moi
j'aurai un système à l'allemande ou vous
avez la droite et la gauche qui se
mettent autour de la table qui prennent
des semaines ça prend des semaines et
qui rédige ensemble un programme de
gouvernement disant l'adsa on est
d'accord ça on n'est pas d'accord ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne s'est pas
fait en france et je le regrette et je
regrette oui je pense que les gens
raisonnables peuvent travailler ensemble
les hommes et les hommes et les femmes
de bonne volonté peuvent travailler
ensemble mais ça ne doit pas être vue du
débauchage individuel ça doit être
quelque chose d'organisé et d'accepter
et de raisonnable sinon à ça fait le jeu
des populistes qui disent regardez ces
gars ils se partagent la petite se
gamelle dans la petite soupe d'un petite
cuisine donc un pacte de gouvernement
quand la demande est nicolas sarkozy
vous le demandez encore moi je lui ai
demandé vous avez vu que j'ai pas eu
beaucoup de succès puisque je suis très
minoritaire de mon parti aucun moment où
vous comprenez que vous êtes
minoritaires et vous arrêtez de le
demander je le regrette peut-être qu'un
jour la société va devenir plus mature
et ça sera possible mais pardon je je
suis minoritaire de mon parti mais je
crois qu'en face à la république en
marche qui n'en voulait pas beaucoup non
plus de ce mode nouveau j'ai un regret
qui est quasi historique camp shira
gagne les élections présidentielle la
deuxième fois face à l'open on va
regretter durant cinq ans on va lui dire
on va dire mais quand même c'est dommage
vous avez été élu dans des conditions
face à jean marie le pen que vous auriez
dû profiter de ce moment pour regrouper
les français recréer du ciment et faire
ce fameux gouvernement à typer qui était
un gouvernement on aurait pu prendre des
gens de droite de gauche de centre pour
bâtir une majorité raisonnable il n'a
pas fait à l'époque chirac mais est ce
que ton argument ce n'était pas le même
que vous ne il ya quelques instants à
savoir de dire mais si on fait ça la
seule opposition se résumera front
national tous les arguments sont
valables je veux dire c'est qu'elle
avantages de la sphère de chirac c'est
qu'on a maintenant du recul de 20 ans
est ce que finalement la france ne
serait pas en meilleur état aujourd'hui
si chirac avait fait ça il ya 20 ans et
donc je me demande est ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de louper encore une fois
une occasion historique de dire ben
voilà la situation est très grave donc
les gens de bonne volonté travailler
ensemble mais pour sa part dont il faut
que la majorité le veuille est ce que la
cgt ne veut pas et ne veut pas
maintenant on a une première visite qui
est qui est de gauche
on a eu pendant cinq ans des premiers
ministres qui étaient de droite est ce
que finalement et là il y aura sûrement
encore au gouvernement des membres dans
l'ancien de votre enseigne phare de
votre famille politique mais qui était
anciennement chez l'élève est ce qu
emmanuel macron il ne fait pas ça a
finalement il ne n'agit pas avec un peu
de gauche un peu de droite ado merdy
diablement emmanuel macron et à créer
des conditions un peu sites de ce type
là mais encore une fois on voit bien que
il y a des ressources humaines desquels
des gens qui ont des qualités que moi
emmanuel macron aurait pu faire profiter
le pays je le regrette c'est ainsi
écouter c'est assez correct et vous
rentrer au gouvernement mais dans le cas
dans le cadre d'un casting de débauchage
individuel dans le cadre de ce que je
vous disais à savoir on se met d'accord
sur aller qu'est ce qu'on fait on se
retrousse les manches collectivement
pour sauver le pays
le même âge et le mcs romanisation ne le
souhaite pas c'est son choix et puis moi
dans ma famille je fais pas vu beaucoup
de volonté de nous soutenir dans cette
affaire donc je laisse tomber mais vous
auriez mais vous auriez aimé être là
ministre de la santé dans saint cannat
philippe juvin le casting c'est là où
vous voyez on pardon je voulais dire on
peut par abc sans vote a fait 2 120
perdant sont débordés machin veut machin
veut c'est est ce que les petits jouant
on veut se mettre d'accord pour sauver
le pays c'est ça le sujet moi je crois
que c'était le moment parce que la
situation est grave points vous avez dit
que j'étais urgentiste je rappelle que
la situation est très grave y compris en
matière de santé on va essayer un prix
en matière de santé ah qu'est ce qu'on
fait on laisse faire le truc on laisse
se débobine est une société qui se
fractionne je moi je regrette pas encore
une fois le choix dépasserait et par la
majorité et non nous aida c'est comme ça
aussi et par vous et par la ligne de
christian jacob qui selon-vous s est
trompé de ligne en choisissant la ligne
d'indépendance là dessus vous êtes
d'accord avec les rebelles mais je comme
vous fout tu me faire absolument dans
mais on est jeudi des noms des choses de
la vie même supa crew visage comme moi
je vais pas dire des choses derrière je
suis minoritaire de mon parti
la suite de l'avenir de votre parti est
ce que votre parti il a encore un avenir
en ayant choisi sec d'abord
est-ce qu'un parti un avenir soit vous
aviez en politique quand vous voyez le
nombre de fois où on a enterré chirac
que je mitterrand et ses skis sont
donnés donc oui moi je crois que le pays
a besoin d'une droite qui est une droite
modérée moi je suis un homme modéré
voilà je préfère la modération la
radicalité européenne libérale qui
croire la décentralisation et qui croit
un principe simple c'est que le pays
peut être sauvé si on fait confiance aux
français raymond aron disait il faut
faire confiance aux potentialités des
individus vous avez j'ai nous avons tous
des savoir-faire des richesses une
intelligence et bien si on libérait ses
intelligences le pays est mieux or
aujourd'hui le contraindront contrôle on
le leur le règlement de telle manière
que ceux qui ont dû à des talents ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer je pense que
c'est ça le vrai sujet des années à
venir et moi je vais porter dans les
années à venir je vais le porter dans ma
famille puis on verra ce ridge à ma
famille dire que l'on va encore rester
en l'état ou est-ce que là aussi blafard
clarifier votre famille entre la droite
modérée et la droite plus dur mais il
vit et choisir une ligne et visionner de
link est encore tenable on a fait 4,7
pour sochaux est pas vain un très très
mauvais score et évidemment il faut
qu'on en tire les leçons enfin ce jeu
celui qui dirait donc tout va bien
madame la marquise évidemment on va en
tirer des leçons et il faut
repartir de zéro à zéro non parce qu'il
ya évidemment il ya des choses mais il
faut repartir de la réflexion politique
en fait c'est pas la première fois qu'on
perd les élections ça fait depuis 2012
ailleurs qu'à part les élections locales
c'est un à park est très important nous
perdons les élections nationales chaque
fois nous disons on va en tirer les
leçons il faut maintenant le vrai bon le
faire il faut en tirer leçon est ce que
le fait d'organiser une foire nationale
avait sélection locale pardon ça vous a
empêchés d'en tirer les leçons justement
alors d'une serre quelque part oui et
non oui et non c'est sûr que c'est sûr
que nous les républicains nous sommes
très puissants au niveau local moi par
exemple je suis candidat dans une
circonscription
les maires me soutiennent et et c'est
vrai que le quotidien des français c'est
lé maire et le président du sénat gérard
larcher avait dit que durant les gilet
jaune ceux qui avaient tenu la
république c'est lé maire moi je crois
beaucoup à ça c'est nous qui sommes là
nous sommes la colonne une colonne
vertébrale locale donc c'est très
important mais c'est vrai d'une certaine
manière vous avez raison on peut faire
peut-être une explication un peu
psychologique un peu de comptoir mais
qui n'est pas inintéressante qui est de
dire que parce que nous avons eu toutes
ces victoires locales nous sommes un peu
endormis sur ses victoires locales alors
c'est victoire locale témoigne est
plutôt de la vitalité de talents locaux
que de la réalité d'un parti qui
existait en tant que parti
indéniablement oui il ya un effet mais
ça n'enlève rien à la richesse locale
fait nous dirigeons des régions des
villes des départements et mine de rien
les gens viennent de chez nous donc moi
je suis très fier de diriger une commune
depuis maintenant plusieurs années et
d'être réélu très large beaucoup plus
largement que la simple étiquette
politique que je conduirai imaginé
pouvoir la trouvaille et christian jacob
va quitter la tête du parti après les
législatives parce que vous êtes
candidats ceux qui nous écoutent et je
dois dire je suis candidat aux
législatives
avec les maires de la circonscription
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
je participerai au débat qui va dit qui
va permettre de définir ce que signifie
être dans une opposition raisonnable
modéré moi je participerai ce débat je
trouve que ce serait un gâchis de pas y
participer c'est une certaine chance
finalement peut se dire finalement on
est tombé si bas c'est une grande chance
je vous dis aujourd'hui je suis non pas
contents très malheureux notre défaite
mais il faut voir le bon côté il ya tout
à reconstruire voilà on va reconstruire
et si la ligne dure l'emportent à
l'issue du congrès puisqu'il va bien
falloir choisir entre d'aline que là
vous vous poserez la question de rester
encore ressenti base d'abord tout le
monde se pose toute sa vie des questions
sur vos choix je sois personnel
professionnel j'imagine que vous posez
salariés donc ça sera pareil
je pense qu'en fait la droite quand elle
a gagné les élections quand elle a
gouverné le pays plus exactement elle a
toujours gouvernés en fait de façon
modérée la droite qui gouverne c'est une
droite modérée sait jamais une droite
radicale donc oui oui je suis à modéré
voilà donc je serai toujours à modérer
donc l'erreur de cette campagne a été de
trop se tourner vers la ligne eric
ciotti
a été tellement atypique la guerre
locaux vides phase william hill sujets
qui sont arrivés ils ont impacté un jour
les historiens essaieront de tirer les
leçons d'une campagne incroyable est-ce
que l'une d'elles soit pas que les
électeurs modérés sont allés chez
emmanuel macron mais indéniablement oui
vous avez raison continuez à les
récupérer salariés à vous si nous sommes
intelligents c'est à dire que si nous
avons cette capacité à dire oui voilà ce
que c'est une droite modérée
intelligente et un centre modéré
intelligente jeu je fais partie de ceux
ci et je vais essayer d'y participer
philippe duval un besoin urgent
s'installe pompidou à paris on va parler
de la situation d urgence à l est
alarmante pour vous cette situation
n'est pas alarmante elle est extrêmement
inquiétante vous avez aujourd'hui
alors on ne se connaît pas le chiffre
exact parce que tout ça est mais je fais
je connais pas un seul service
d'urgences pas un seul service d'urgence
en france qui puisse me dire tout va
bien très c'est très compliqué pour deux
raisons la principale la première c'est
que comme la médecine de ville va mal
est bien le seul endroit qui est ouvert
matin midi et soir la nuit les jours
fériés c'est quoi ces les urgences donc
tout dysfonctionnement de la médecine de
ville arrive aux urgences tous première
raison est deuxième raison mais c'est un
métier d'une dureté
inimaginable physiquement moralement
donc les gens n'en peuvent plus que ce
soit pour les médecins les infirmiers
les aides soignants les internes c'est
un métier très difficile passionnant
passionnant mais très difficile et c'est
pour ça que les gens disent finalement
on arrête c'est pour ça que vous avez
des ben daoud des démissions partout en
france même dans les grands centres donc
nous on essaye de tenir
le délai gens à travailler il ya des
endroits ça se passe mieux qu'ailleurs
et moi j'ai la chance d'être dans un
grand hôpital qui est la science
publique hôpitaux de paris où on est
encore quand je compare à ce que ce que
vous vivez un certain nombre de nos
voisins on est on est préservée même si
c'est difficile on est relativement
préservé mais oui la situation est grave
parce que c'est le témoin d'un
dysfonctionnement général du système
et mais quand on dit ça on essaye d'en
fait de dire aux réalités il n'y a pas
de solution parce que c'est tellement
global mais il ya aussi un sujet
spécifique aux urgences pour par exemple
je crois que ce n'est pas normal
qu'aujourd'hui on puisse aller aux
urgences comme ça librement à 2 heures
du matin parce qu'on a un bouton sur la
fesse droite depuis trois mois tiens à 2
heures du matin je vais aller consulter
c'est ça les urgences est pas ça c'est
pas normal comme je préfère un prix ah
bah oui bon ça fait deux ans que je fais
une tribune il ya deux ans avec quel
moment mon collègue et copains mathias
jargon on a publié dans un grand journal
national est une des propositions
confusion à l'époque c'était le système
danois au danemark vous devez prendre
votre téléphone avant d'aller aux
urgences bonjour jai sagesse agca est ce
que je peux aller aux urgences on vous
dit oui vous avez dans telle urgence ou
dentelle ou vous dit non vous n'y allez
pas mais j'ai une proposition cette
attaque demain à 10h vous errez chez le
docteur dupont rue de grenelle il ya un
rendez-vous de libre et ses bases les
choses sont organisées je crois qu'il
faut trier en arriver aux urgences il
faut pas permettre à tout le monde
d'aller aux urgences facilement mais
s'il n'y a pas que ça il ya aussi la
dureté je crois que les urgentistes qui
travaillent nuit et jour nuit et jour
vous comprenez ce que sage moi je fais
plus de garde la nuit j'ai arrêté et
donc je fais plus de garde la nuit et
donc j'ai une pensée pour ceux qui
continuent en faire mais j'ai arrêté de
compter le nombre de gardes que je
faisais le jour où je suis arrivé je
suis arrivé à 1000m une nuit passée à
l'hôpital en dehors de chez moi est ce
que vous connaissez beaucoup de
professions où vous faites mille fois
vous allez dormir ailleurs sur votre
lieu de travail en plus de votre travail
du jour
cette démo est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
foutu et les urgentistes double la nuit
double de ce qu'ils sont payés
aujourd'hui double sinon ils arrêteront
de travailler est ce que j'en ai cette
situation catastrophique après amener
une rupture de soins dans le pays ah bah
déjà on sait qu'il ya des gens qui ne se
font pas bien soigné en france bien sûr
et particulièrement de pulco vide il ya
des papiers qui montre que ce sont pas
dans des papiers français mais
internationaux mais je pense que la
situation est la même en france locaux
vides a montré que la désorganisation du
système lyoko vide a montré qu'il ya des
gens qui ont repoussé des soins y
compris des soins grave pour le cancer
pour les maladies du coeur pour les
maladies psychiatriques et sont en
retard de traitement oui oui bien sûr la
désorganisation du système est
importante eh bien vous savez la même
période la mortalité infantile c'est un
sujet qui est connexe mais qui montre la
dégradation du système la mortalité
infantile en france a augmenté alors
qu'elle baisse ailleurs c'est pas pour
rien quand même l'une des solutions est
ce que c'est de réintégrer les soignants
qui sont suspendues parce que non
vaccinés alors c'est pas la solution
parce qu'en fait ils sont très peu
nombreux donc ça va rien changer fait au
système c'est un débat comme on aime le
mettre sur la table parce qu'en fait
comme beaucoup de gens ne réfléchissent
pas à l'ispa travaille pas je parle d un
certain nombre de gens qui le donne
politique et de femmes politiques comme
ils ont aucune idée de ce qu'il faut
faire il vous donne le truc à la mode
les soignants non vaccinés mais soigné
en vacciner c'est rien c'est rien ça il
n'y en a quasiment pas ou très peu tout
cas si demain les soignants le vacciner
revenait à l'hôpital ça ne changerait
rien à la capacité de l'hôpital de vous
soyez ou pas vous soigner avant sur le
crâne puisque vous êtes parti vous 15
rue en ukraine point évidemment soient
soignés les blessés l'ukraine et vous
avez reçue la semaine dernière 4 si je
me trompe pas casta gère le craignait il
sait à l'hôpital justement là aussi pour
les formes et quel bilan peut on tirer
de cette expérience bah je tire
plusieurs bilans sains c'est un pays où
les gens sont très courageux tout le
monde se prépare la guerre là-bas il n'y
a pas une commune où les légendes 18 à
60 ans ne se prépare pas à se battre à
faire face à une occupation et puis moi
dans ces groupes-là j'enseignais le
sauvetage au combat c'est à dire comment
arrêter une hémorragie au combat puisque
les combattants à la guerre meurent dans
les premières minutes démarrage et le
deuxième enfin j'ai eu il ya beaucoup de
leçons qu'il faut tirer la deuxième
leçon c'est je n'ai eu angers raconté
donc je vous racontais de nouveau gelé
eu quand j'ai quitté l'ukraine je passe
la frontière polonaise sam est de 3
heures parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
contrôles ou celle des hommes ne peuvent
pas sortir d'ukraine donc il y avait les
contrôles sont très strictes et je
franchi la frontière je suis dans une
voiture le cros bagnole avec deux
ukrainiens un très fort tiges qui
conduisent ils disent il parle il parle
pas un mot d'anglais ils parlent pas et
moi je parle pas ukrainien et ils
parlent pas français et donc quand on
discute avec avec le téléphone et puis à
un moment il avant les radios qui
fonctionne et la radio qui chante des
chansons anglaises un plus tôt et puis
brutalement joe dassin joe dassin c'est
si tu n'existais pas c'est cette chanson
il se trouve que je les enregistre et
donc j'ai publié c'était incroyable je
filmais et joe dassin qui jaillit de la
voiture si tu n'existais pas vous venez
de passer en europe je passe d'un pays
où c'est la guerre ou peut-être dix fois
par jour on a les sirènes le jour la
nuit
la guerre est permanente et les
bombardements sont permanents par tout
un pays où tout est calme en 300 mètres
et jonas of tu n'existais pas bah c'est
ça la plus grande des manceaux c'est que
j'ai compris que nous étions des enfants
gâtés que nous n'avions pas
qu'on compréhension collective que nous
vivions dans un pays en paix grâce à
l'europe grâce à l'europe un dernier mot
était libre je veux un premier cas
suspect de varier singe a été détectée
hier sur le territoire français en
ile-de-france habituellement c'est une
maladie qui est cantonné à la trique la
ya plusieurs cas qui ont été détectés en
europe et en amérique du nord il faut
s'inquiéter en tout cas il faut se voir
inquiéter je ne je ne sais pas c'est une
mousse est une maladie animale qui se
transmet à l'homme qui existent en
afrique à bas bruit il ya quelques cas
européens qui ont été écrites puis 2018
en particulier au royaume-uni et c'est
vrai que depuis quelques jours il ya des
cas en europe qui ont deux
caractéristiques principales outre le
fait qu'ils soient plus fréquents parce
qu'on en voyait très peu 1 les gens qui
l'ont n'ont pas voyagé en afrique donc
c'est qu'il ya probablement des chaînes
de contamination locale chez nous en
europe portugal royaume-uni danemark
france maintenant allemagne peut-être et
il ya une incidence plus important me
semble-t-il chez des hommes qui ont des
relations sexuelles avec des hommes donc
ce sont de fait
qu'il faut interpréter avec sérénité
prudence
sans aucune panique bien entendu et
qu'il faut regarder
la question des épidémies c'est une
question qui nécessite de la rigueur
dans l'analyse scientifique
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter vous posez
les jours je sais pas qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire c'est être prêt à l'émergence
de nouvelles maladies virales
infectieuses bactériennes ce que vous
voulez par esther dans les années à
venir il faut que nous apprenions des
erreurs de la non préparation du coc
vide à être prêts à faire face à de
nouvelles menaces c'est quasiment un
exercice en temps réel
il faut laisser les autorités travailler
mais il faut que les nôtres soient
prêtes aussi merci et je vous remercie
beaucoup de m'avoir était notre invité
ce matin
[Musique]